we just had a written statement um from
prince harry's team
i can read it to you now it says our
mother was an incredible woman
who dedicated her life to service she
was resilient
brave and unquestionably honest the
ripple effect the culture of
exploitation
and unethical practices ultimately took
her life
to those who've taken some form of
accountability thank you for owning it
that is the first step towards justice
and truth yet what deeply concerns me is
that practices like these
and even worse are still widespread
today
then and now it's bigger than one outlet
one network
or one publication our mother lost her
life because of this
and nothing has changed by protecting
her legacy
we protect everyone and uphold the
dignity with which she lived her life
let's remember who she was and what she
stood for
so that's the statement there from
prince harry following the publication
of lord dyson's report earlier on today
i i suppose
at times like this i should be saying to
you look this is these are deeply
unusual statements aren't they from
princes william and harry that the
personal nature the tone
that they struck but perhaps we're all
too quick to forget the fact these two
men lost their mother as young boys
and when you look back at the pictures
of them with their mother
you cannot forget that these are two men
then boys who were deeply scarred by the
way that their mother was treated
by the press and today we've had this
report from lord dyson which has
exposed the practices the tactics that
were used
by martin beshear the cover-up then
within the bbc
that it was fake documents that
ultimately led lord spencer
to introducing um diana to
martin beshear but yes it is absolutely
extraordinary i think if we take
prince william's statement first the
fact that he decided that he wanted to
step out
in front of the cameras he didn't just
want to put this down on paper
he's also released it on his own social
media this evening
i think the fact that he talks about the
fact that this made my parents
relationship
worse the fact that he also goes on to
say and this is something certainly i
hadn't thought of that actually
if the complaints and concerns first
raised in 1995 were actually
investigated properly
then his mother would have known that
she'd been deceived before she died
but also i think what's interesting in
prince william's statement is
that final sentence in which he said
these failings
identified by investigative journalists
and i think it's at that point you can
then point the difference between the
two brothers statements
certainly with prince harry in recent
years we have been so used to him
taking a side swipe at the press yes
there is a great deal of heart
and upset within the statement from
prince harry the fact that he says that
ultimately these
unethical practices took her life
but also again he is now reflecting on
the media that we have today
and trying to say look we need to learn
the lessons from the past
even though it was 26 years ago but yes
i think at least here we know the
brothers have had their differences
but they are tonight united in
condemning the bbc